Drone footage from the site of the train
crash wreckage is being cleared from the
scene but residents fear the impact on
the environment is less visible
the anger was clear at a recent town
hall meeting with many insisting that
they were being lied to by authorities
who maintain there is no health risk
[Music]
the CEO of the train company Norfolk
Southern visited the town to meet with
some residents leaving many less than
satisfied with what they heard it's a
terrible accident
it falls on their shoulders it's a train
but the CEO Alan Shaw declined to answer
specific questions about cleanup
concerns so we're being completely
transparent completely collaborative
with the Ohio EPA on this and
transportation secretary Pete buttej has
made public a letter he sent to shore
calling for accountability writing the
people of East Palestine cannot be
forgotten nor can their pain be simply
considered the cost of doing business
and questions are being raised in
Congress a senate committee is calling
on rail companies to provide information
on safety and the transportation of
hazardous material a move that for the
residents of East Palestine Ohio comes
far too late
Mike Hanna Al Jazeera